and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review how to train your
dragon toilers dances please
filled with my games in the old Viking
accent is prepared only death directed
by his CDs in there these children in
the by Inglot who for some reason don't
have an accent
they spend weird Beauty at the Bistro
nobody has a French accent except the
kendo stick
maybe this because he was planing so
anyway this fighting lady's attacked by
dragon in the vices job is to chase the
Dragons I chase dragons once oh no it's
that way you think I'm talking about
drugs buddies wouldn't we just want to
kill dragon she wants to be finding in
the boy's name is pickup it's a weenie
it's like maybe a kickoff for consumed
tight or Chester mixed with a
fire-breathing demon you know like so he
decides to name the dragon toothless
even though he has teeth but in person
it looks like he doesn't have teeth and
then he close the mouth things are so
cool it really seems like you're dancing
pushing these mega flame let me figure
out why the Dragons a bit stealing food
this whole time faces I can see this
dragon which is a little strange
why did it beat this one dragon knew
you'd never feed themselves oh honey
sorry is the nature of dragons for 2,000
schools have to make you food you'll get
oh I'll find you you probably that but
if I do I'll keep you under so he the
father find something he's been training
two dragons and I think it's really bad
and he's like to a doctor by sign well
technically I should have been well
metaphorically you're not so the father
tries to kill the feed bags ragged but
he's like what - no I drank it was that
big or bad or dragon but I hate computer
Keys commands to save the day and the
riving sixty no dragons so six little
drag these kid destroyed greet people in
bed pet dragons game time so confused
but involves being Brad dragon is
chasing after toothless but truthfully
shoots an exploding fireball inside of
him canopy bed record combos how does
the little fireball make it drinkable
geralyn's
awesome the only downside to all of this
is that hiccup loses his name I lost my
leg once I left it in Canada to Train
Your Dragon is a really good movie
especially the 3d the three tiers
awesome but seriously what are they
gonna bring back smellivision
don't you wish you could smell me
through the